well it's it's really a pleasure to be
here for the ATF as a my first yeah
that's all I'm sorry for the 1815 it's
always hard following Michael Raymond
I'm glad there was no opportunity asking
questions and would have been fun but i
I've known Michael a really long time
and I knew or no I'm sorry no dick a
little less I want to say something
about that the one thing Michael made a
comment about the 90th and I'm sure
we'll hear more of those I'd rather say
to dick that your initial career is
really to going well and I look forward
to to continue for the rest of your
career to do at least as well so good so
I first met Michael are we flipping
correctly yo is that coming up oh I see
it's it we did this on my machine and
now it's running on this machine can you
read this is it work ok this is the fear
of moving from one machine to another
all right well let's see if it works I
can do a little bit outside so anyway
and what what happened well I think the
first conference ever went to was
something called I Phipps said he won't
even ever been to a knife IPPs yes yes a
couple break okay so I knew Michael
actually from grad school long story why
at I pips I pulled out a couple of
papers you know this one is by Michael
Ray but i still remember the talk
Michael give such as fabulous talks it
was on impediments to AI essentially
talking about work on logical decision
systems very neat you also may notice
that there are only as far as I could
tell for talks at this very large
conference and it was a chance I got to
meet dick harp of course have already
knew Michael very well ok for talk like
this I didn't want to make
something very technical but I wanted to
talk about at least I didn't know you're
going to say that but this work that
dick and I did maybe in a little bit of
some extensions and hopefully you'll
enjoy that so this is this is coming out
really we ship yes it is your way to
know can you help or we could use my
machine it's right there terrific and
you always I was reminding diktat one
time he came to Georgia Tech before I
was there to give a keynote and he
worked on the airplane making his slides
kisses a long flight to Atlanta and
that's you know we all do things like
that and then he got off and we're
taking it to lunch and he was going to
give the keynote right after lunch to
probably even larger group and he said
you know I tried some new pens on the
plane on his little acetates he said
they look a little faint but I'm not
really sure how it's going to work and
I'm thinking oh my let's let us all hope
you gave a great talk but the slides
were invisible so I guess I could do the
same so let's see if this works oh
that's better okay thank you so bad joke
but it's his idiot okay I guess we only
have to add a few more bits as time goes
on does that help okay and these were
just some random pictures of dick over
the years I thought I was going to throw
a couple of ringers in but they really
aren't dick ok and again here is you can
see there as Michaels talk that was
really great one of the other stories
here isn't very many theoretical people
talking in this very large conference in
Sweden and that's where I met dick so
okay there's this thing called carp lip
that I guess you mentioned and you
probably all know this but you know the
theorem basically is the way I used to
say is if satisfaction is easy if it's
got small circuits then we get this
collapse of the polynomial hierarchy
what I always thought was interesting
about this and we tell my students is
that I i read a number of papers I might
have even written to some of these we're
in the introduction we would make
throwaway remarks and the indict
reductions are really interesting part
of the paper because you don't really
necessarily think it through write your
theorems I'm sure you get right you
think through very carefully you try to
prove the theorems very carefully but
sometimes in the introduction and maybe
the conclusion you just throw out
something and we've made the mistakes
they are over the years and I remember
at the time there are a lot of papers
that said well obviously if something
has a small circuit there's no way to
get an upper bound in a Turing machine
uniform model because you can have
undecidable theorems you can I mean
languages and all sorts of such things
but of course the trick here is that sad
is special and I want to talk a little
bit about that not so much that you
don't know this result but you'll see
why ok I want to just do that there are
two other things in this paper and
that's what I want to do one is the
famous notation of a complexity class /
the advice bits I assume lots of you
know this notation this is really due to
dick I'm going to join paper and joint
results but you know he wrote the the
draft that included this I thought was
very brilliant we don't get any money
for the use of this we did not trade
market even though I have a trademark I
guess that's probably illegal I wish we
did but maybe we can have a paypal
account and you can all send us a nickel
every time you use it that would be
great there's also another cold part
about this paper is there's a whole
section you've never read probably
you've never read the paper right I mean
everybody knows this result probably
right but I suspect a lot of you've
never read the actual paper indeed what
I looked
up on the on the web I'm I couldn't even
find my own copy but if you've forgotten
approved here's here's some help at the
complexity meeting in 2010 they had tote
bags that had essentially the proof of
our theorem now i remember when i heard
about i wasn't at that meeting
unfortunate but i heard about this
several things he went on line one you
know your life's work is on a tote bag
you know so so is that really good maybe
it's really good or maybe that's i don't
know maybe that's really bad i mean the
other way to look at it is you know
again you know we have some copyright
position here dec you know where we can
I mean they printed 200 of these about
my permission anyway but ok we'll let it
go all right obviously I need at least
one proof here but here's the original
paper hears us a little piece of it and
for a variety of reasons the fame you
know the main theorem we sort of pushed
aside we had this other whole section we
called round-robin method and it really
wasn't about sat it was about something
else and probably I don't want to show a
handsome people because people never do
that but I sort of forgot about this and
it came up in an interesting context
that's the rest of what I want to
present today but the round-robin method
is a whole big section in this paper
dick do you remember this no no he
doesn't record and if you notice this is
not even anyway it's not a lot tech we
apologized it for history kaneva that
but was a little early in the years okay
the whole idea there was of course we
had some something like this yeah we
were thinking about chess I'm sorry
today we're going to think about chess
way there we were think about obviously
generalized games if you like think
about a game that's piece of space
complete pick your favorite game
obviously eight by eight is not but in
general you know chesus and and the idea
is Alice has two different Bob's that
each claim to be very good players at
her disposal and obviously we're
computer scientists to really make it n
so she may have many
these and her job is to use these
players to win this position which let's
assume that she's white and it's a
winning position for like just assume
that and she wants to know what to do
but but the point is alice is not a
chess players it's not very good at that
so she has the advice of her to experts
so you all get the sort of general setup
I guess it's it's some sense related to
work I guess we'll hear at the end in
the conference from man eve LOM on what
humans can do but it's something we
don't want Alice to cheat by saying well
I'll run an exponential search she's got
to do something really simple everybody
you say with me so the deal is Alice
basically can use her experts by running
you know instead of an obvious thing but
I guess we did at first running a
round-robin tournament and trying to
move then using the players against each
other and the assumption is she's told
that one of these players is perfect and
the other players may be very good or
very bad or terrible or you know you
know make some mistakes and the deal is
her job is not to discover who is the
optimal player and turns out I don't
think she can do that if I'm sure she
can and we actually say that I think in
the papers something like there's a
curious subtle point that you can't
actually figure that out but you can
figure out an optimal move right and you
play them against each other it's not
all that difficult all right everybody
happy with that so Alice wins I'll just
leave it with that but things have
changed today so leaving forward a few
years chess is now lots of people are
interested in in computer chess so I've
worked a lot with Ken Regan and my blog
and elsewhere on chest so that's what
we're going to talk about sort of
building on that old result trying to do
something a little more modern all right
ok now when I first heard about this I
in my head you should know and i'll give
you some more data but computers are
much better than humans and i don't mean
everyone in the room assuming we don't
have some very strong players I mean
everyone on the planet computers no
longer can be defeated at least in a
long enough tournament they're just like
a loose two chests machines but it's not
i guess the picture I've drawn or you
know I'm not tried but you know copied
is a supercomputer center maybe you know
worth 100 million dollars we have lots
of computers that's what I always
thought but it's actually this it's your
smartphone and probably in the future it
could be your light bulb or you know it
doesn't take that much computing power
running the state-of-the-art algorithms
that you can get either free or for
modest amounts of money on you know on
the internet they're very very well
optimized they do alpha beta search they
do other tricks but they just can't lose
and you don't read you don't really need
much computing power matter of fact as
an aside they've actually don't know
what to do with more computing power
because they start to run into problems
notice if we go back to the
supercomputer in setting they'd love to
run on that if they could but it doesn't
paralyze very well it's one of those
interesting problems so they really are
running mostly single core or very few
core so here are some numbers for you
and and I'll just put this up yeah so
well that's good the the there's a
rating in chess maybe everyone knows
this élow ratings it's it's I guess
anywhere from around a thousand and
although you know you can be lower up to
into the 3000 Ranger no one's gone
beyond any of computer or humans this
this data is a little older but from ken
2850 i think is roughly what the world
champion plays that though he's actually
not been playing very well lately but
that's another story you know humans do
have sometimes get distracted or make
mistakes or gets hired the computer
stone when this was collected the
the computer engines and running the
standard algorithms we're playing quite
a bit better and the way to think of
this rating is if you're a couple of
hundred i think it's about three above
someone else you basically should win on
most of the games you should win about
75% so that means you know maybe maybe
magnus the current world champion could
play in one of these engines he doesn't
want to maybe he could win a game but if
he played you know 20 he'll just be
destroyed and it's no fun so they don't
do it anymore one side effect if you
read our blog or talk to Ken Regan is
this makes cheating a huge huge
interesting problem for chess because if
we all work this was a chess tournament
and we're about to pair off for the
first round if you've got a laptop in
your pocket I'm not suggesting you would
cheat but maybe people sometimes go to
the restroom they've been caught the
machines behind parts of the restroom
accessories you always say they
sometimes have had friends in the
audience you know doing like first-rate
there's their base coaches giving hand
signals there are lots of ways to cheat
apparently someone was caught with
something under their arm and it sounds
kind of kind of little gross anyway but
if you could get you know some bits to
you you can play really well and one of
the things they're not going to talk
about Ken statistical work but one of
the things that that he's been doing a
lot and you should either invite him and
read some of his stuff on our blog he
tries to do statistical analysis to see
if you claim your 2300 player but you're
actually playing at 28 you know for too
long a stretch so they're very
interesting action machine learning and
statistical questions that he's still
working on all right so how do you beat
the machine so people have this idea I
decided not to include the cartoon I
don't know why they like to call them
centaurs everything you're like it's
part human and part animal and
it should really be part machine part
human so it the deal is this what if you
have access legally to a computer like
this one which is more than adequate to
play today I think it's certainly in the
you know low 3000 range can you as a
human with this machine play better than
the machine and they've done some very
small experiments not a lot 10 says yes
the data I have here is from an old
tournament we're adding the human and
it'll about a hundred points which isn't
a huge amount but it's it's not obvious
to me why it wouldn't be worse I mean
you know I actually what I think about
it at first when you told me this I
thought we'll wait if I have access to a
computer I mean I'm really a weak player
if I tell them she no no no don't do
that I think you know this is a better
move and then it's sack sack made that
would be bad right i mean so why do
humans help and the answer I think is
not well known but not understood yet
but certainly one possibility is that
machines are really good at tactical
stuff don't ever get in a situation with
the computers where what they're doing
is basically tactical they're just going
to kill you but there are these
interesting strategic positions where
they just seem to get lost even though
the looking 20 moves ahead they just
don't know where they're going so maybe
the human somehow could say something
and there's what got me thinking about
this is we were involved in a big
conference call about a month ago when
we're up in Buffalo working together and
it was with people who are trying to
organize these human computer
experiments to see if humans can be
helpful to computers in and obviously
for chess you know this is a general AI
question right a really interesting as
we automate more and more things using
machine learning and other tools are we
going to just hand it over to the
computers or humans going to stay in the
loop and maybe add value and I think you
know I think the answer is probably yes
so the nice thing about chess is a very
well defined kind of specialized world
and that's what you're talking about all
right so what we're interested in that's
it like I said like everything I wanted
to think about a specific problem so
here's the problem i wanted to look at
so imagine you have Alice again and it's
the same position although that doesn't
matter and I've drawn to chess engines
and then they actually don't use the
arms very much at the high end machines
that just software there are people that
are trying to also pick the pieces up
and move them that actually matters if
you play speech as where the computers
kill you I mean there's no chance but of
course if they have to move the pieces
fest I think we still win because I tend
to knock over other pieces which is a
bad thing in your play chess so so I
know when Ken plays against these robot
arms that he allows them to knock pieces
over he just gets killed and he's about
a 2400 player which you know its
international master level so just below
glory grandmaster ok so so you've gone
Alice and she has access to say the two
you know again think to think n but some
number of these experts it sounds like
the problem we just you know did in this
section no one reads so when I first
thought about this know it sounds pretty
straightforward but you know run the
round robin but I want to change this a
little bit this picture of palio so I
was trying to think of the simplest
problem that there might be interesting
and the problem here is that what if
Alice has access to these two machines
but I tell you neither one is perfect
that each of them make errors and the
biggest simplest problem i can think
about the HR going to make one or earth
by that i mean there's some position
among the large finite but huge number
of physicians out there and chess where
each machine will make an error that is
if the machine I know in chess you can
win lose or draw let's just make it
winter lose it make it simple for the
moment what I mean by that very
precisely is if the position is winning
the machine in some position will make a
losing Luke alright you may never find
that position in
baby is a trivial position that you
would notice as a human it makes them
view some very complicated position
somewhat like the one on I guess we had
up on the board on the screen it may be
something else and the other assumptions
will assume that the two machines don't
ever make the error on the same place
like an independence assumption which we
do all the time I have no reason to
believe that's true right but we're more
than willing to make that assumption so
the question is can Alice still win can
she win a one game and the answer is now
I should do if you do the round robin
trick I don't think it quite works if
you think about it for a minute when you
start playing them against each other
you don't know if they make mistakes or
not and I think you can get misled
especially if they make more than one
error but certainly if they're both
faulty on some positions it seems clear
that the old techniques won't work so I
don't actually know how to answer this
question and if you know the answer you
instantly check your email or do
something else and tell me later is that
all right so you don't embarrass me too
much during the talk so everybody I know
is it too early in the morning and I
just really not funny okay I mean I'm
sorry okay have you heard I'll just tell
some dick jokes now no okay so so here's
what she can do so I claim that one
reason maybe we would have looked at
this is first of all when we wrote this
paper so long ago errors you know we
weren't so much interested in things
they were approximately correct right
that's the more modern notion so when we
were looking dick and I at you know
Alice be given a collection of experts
we assume one was perfect than the
others who care you know they made
errors now we're looking at alice is
given a whole bunch of experts the
general case would be and they each make
some arrows but I'm starting with the
simplest case we're just too and I claim
that there's now a probabilistic
algorithm where Alice will be able to
succeed and win Whitley
some well I guess a quarter at least
some decent probability now you might
say well you know that's not all that
good but notice if you take the Machine
and run it by itself against you know a
perfect player it might lose every time
on this position right and you know each
machine so they notice it's not that
they make a mistake in this position but
they make a mistake later on it and how
do you know that alice is not a strong
player so getting ready for this car
fest talk you know I wanted to do
something linked to something we had
done and I thought I had a really clever
algorithm place I was deterministic and
worked in the general case and it fell
through so i'm presenting a
probabilistic algorithm that at least
does something and i invite anyone who
wants to talk to me or has a solution
you know so the general case we can talk
about but this seems like an interesting
problem now and it and this at least I
hope you believe agree with that notice
I mean there's some more general
question you have you have experts that
make errors so what can you do so she
hasn't really maybe I'll just say she
has a really really dumb strategy right
so everybody could probably all see the
strategy so strategy is simply she just
flips a fair coin and takes the advice
of you know one of the engines that's it
all right really simple the trouble with
that so I guess I can advance the
trouble with that strategy is the idea
is that you know in that position and
they both might do well or they both
might make well I can't vote make
mistakes I some but they may do
different moves they may not agree
notice in chess there's a very important
point that in a position there may be
many winning MOOCs and it may be of
course many losing moose so if she does
this in the game less you know 50 moves
which is not uncommon
you know that looks like it could be
some strategy like tuna minus 50 which
is not also good I mean it's not that
terrible because if she simply weren't
made random moves her strategy you know
because I think the average is about 20
some moves per turn so if you just flip
coins you're winning percentage would be
almost 0 to minus 50 is pretty small too
and the reason that works is um let's
see I guess I I'm just I'm just saying
that I mean this is a formal way of
saying she gets the moves from two
players she flipped the coin she makes
the mood and she goes on so it's one of
these you know very standard things we
see this is like the baby this case I
guess you can imagine where you have a
really really simple algorithm and the
whole argument which is not it is also
fairly trivial is well Ferrell is
trivial but it's very simple argument
but I have to show you the argument a
second the argument is that this doesn't
do that badly right and maybe you all
see it i'll just draw a picture so it
turns out they're really let me explain
a notation so the red dot stands for a
chest position and W&L me know you made
a winning move or losing move okay and
notice you can't have an ll because that
would mean both machines made a mistake
at the same position so that's
disallowed now there there may be ways
around at and indeed i thought i had a
way but let's put this morning leave
that so it could be you're in one of
these of courses another flip you know
it could be w ell or LW so they're
really three cases but the crew the
critical point is if both machines have
made a correct move then alice is in
great shape because whatever you know
the coin flip doesn't matter doesn't
matter how you win you just have to win
but on the other hand if it's a if it's
a win-lose when you flip the coin you
might lose but the good news is half the
time you do it well and of course the
critical last point is that every time
you do that because it's a review
continuing the game the end could go on
for many moods is the the advice engines
are burning up their errors because they
only have a small number of errors two
to get you in trouble so you're not
going to see that you're not going to be
really flipping a coin most the time
that matters most of the time will be a
win-win and every now and then will be a
win-lose you have no idea and else will
be very well now I believe she'd say I
think you let me just do one more I
think I'm about on time I think I can do
a little bit better like I can do the
square root of this so in other words I
don't just flip a coin I do something
else so I'll do that offline or talk to
anyone who is interested well I know
there's a deterministic how it works
perfectly in the case of I guess m is
the number of errors but right now I can
do a little bit better but in there I
can't have Alice just flip a coin I have
to have her do some investigation and
try the try a little bit like a
round-robin try the engines against
themselves and gather some information
so i get a better bias on my coin flip
so you know that seems seems kind of
interesting and it's back to the
beginning when we started where you're
playing against these experts and now we
allow errors and you know again and I've
thought of even doing some experiments
with real engines to see if you take
this and play two engines against and
you know a third will they actually do
better because you're sort of somehow
getting around their mistakes and
obviously it would be really neat if we
could do something like where the
engines make epsilon some you know
epsilon fraction of physicians they make
an error and prove something along those
lines and hopefully we'll have that
before the 90th meeting for dick and I
guess I'll stop I think I have a minute
or two or a few seconds anyway for some
questions thank you very much
Oh time yes yes thank you so the
question was you go we can at least do
yeah with just the two errors well oh
I'm sorry I could repeat which is that
but something so you just pick one of
the engines and say I'll trust it yeah
right but but I realized that that that
doesn't work because we because sort of
it whichever one she tried to go with
the I she might still wind up losing she
might hit another pot hole yeah yeah
exactly sorry but what you do have a way
to get around of it you have to have
some communication i can talk to you
know be thrilled to do that Oh is there
I'm glad you should keep away from this
for feedback happen I'm dicks partner so
I guess I'm biased but I've been living
with this chess and not not having been
a player so it's kind of all foreign to
me but I wanted to ask you can you
generalize your findings about chest to
other high-risk behaviors in other
realms you were supposed to ask what
happens a comer trail friend of mine
once told her partner always ask of the
craft during conference what about the
countable case you know where
everything's always finite thank you
gosh it yeah no wait she knows that it's
like a planted question I guess I didn't
expect that
so maybe that's like plan it wasn't
planted it completely spontaneous we're
using chess as a kind of metaphor in the
sense it's well defined it has you know
fixed rules there's a lot of data one of
the cool things as can is collected
literally every game ever played that is
recorded you know in tournaments so he's
got like you know five million games or
something in the last 100 years so but
we do view this as potentially using
experts in other you know maybe more
practical you know every chance is kind
of cool but there's not a lot of money
in chess for example a lot of impact
perhaps so maybe if you have experts
that make errors in other situations can
you do better than what Don was saying
instead of picking one which is sort of
what we tend to do now right we hire an
expert or pick a program and use it or
build an expert system but what we're
talking about here is maybe having
separate ones and by the way there is
apparently i descend with this there is
real data back in chess that there are a
whole bunch of various strong programs
and they do make mistakes on different
positions I mean they have examples
where one of the machines one of the
programs will blunder make a mistake in
this position the other one won't so
there's actually you know some
experimental data on thank you is there
anything else or I think I've used up my
time anyway well thank you again it's
real honor to well